il y a une parlementaire du
rassemblement national qui vous écoute
avec intérêt Marie Estelle Dupont elle
s'appelle Caroline Parmentier et elle
vous adresse ce message merci à votre
chroniqueuse de ne pas mettre tous les
parlementaires dans le même sac le mot
tout parti confondu n'est pas honnête
en cuisine qu'on peut pas vraiment dire
en direct à la télévision à cette
heure-là mais vous me l'avez confié
pourquoi est-ce qu'on dit ça on branle
les asperges c'est le moment
les députés du rassemblement national
ont un comportement impeccable et
responsable Caroline Parmentier député
du Pas-de-Calais
ton café le rassemblement national sur
le fond pour améliorer le texte ou en
montrer les limites
Ménard qui le dit non mais d'abord enfin
Robert Ménard dit beaucoup de ce cheese
donc c'est quand même pas non plus une
jauge moi je vais vous dire Marine Le
Pen c'est quelqu'un qui vraiment
comprend la société française c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas déconnecté
toutes les campagnes qui a réalisé sur
le terrain à Hénin-Beaumont etc lui a
permis de comprendre ce qui était qu'un
français ce qui était revendications
tandis que
Eric Zemmour c'est plutôt un homme de
bureau qui est dans ses livres et qui
n'a jamais compris comment vivait à
quelqu'un qui habite dans les Ardennes
ou quelqu'un qui habite en banlieue
oui on vous écoute oui bonjour à tous
bonjour Madame Le Pen soyez assuré
Madame Le Pen de mon respect et de mon
vote assuré pour 2027 quand
on s'envoie en milieu d'après-midi une
tornade se forme au loin sur ses
collines du sud-ouest de la Creuse
elle se dirige ensuite vers le petit
village de Pontarion
un phénomène météo soudain extrêmement
bref
mais d'une grande violence
cette villa motorisée est censée
résister à des ouragans de force 4 son
prix 5 millions d'euros
mais cette architecte le sait ce n'est
pas avec des maisons individuelles hors
de prix que nous pourrons faire face
collectivement à la montée des eaux
[Musique]
Cohen conçoit aussi des immeubles
flottants
des quartiers entièrement sur l'eau
pour lui le changement climatique nous
oblige à entrer dans une nouvelle ère
celle des villes mobiles
on perçoit l'étendue des dégâts dans
cette commune d'à peine 360 habitants
le bourg est au 3/4
détruit au niveau des toitures
les services de sécurité sont venus en
force avec les pompiers mais bon là lui
arrivant je pense que on va arrêter
plein de choses
imaginez Paris
imaginez la Concorde l'hôtel de ville ou
le Louvre inondé
ces images ne sont pourtant pas celles
d'un film catastrophe
elles sont une projection de ce qui
pourrait arriver dans 10 ans un an ou
peut-être même dans quelques semaines
ne vous fiez ni au ciel gris ni aux
quelques gouttes de pluie tomber ces
dernières heures en Ardèche la
sécheresse est déjà là et la préfecture
a placé le nord du département au niveau
d’alerte 2 sur 4 une vigilance jaune
donc et les premières restrictions d'eau
qui vont avec moi ça fait 30 ans je suis
ici c'est la première fois je vois ça
c'est très tôt habituellement quand il y
a un arrêté préfectoral c'est l'été
car un tel scénario s'est déjà produit
en 1910 la truffe centenal une énorme
crue de la Seine qui survient en moyenne
tous les 100 ans et dont le retour
serait inévitable
avec une capitale paralysée des
transports qui ne fonctionnent plus
pendant des mois des milliers
d'évacuations une panne générale pour
des millions de personnes
c'est la souffrance qui se manifeste
instantanément sans une chaleur me
monter dans tout le visage
pour le psychanalyste on rit aussi pour
se protéger c'est un peu comme un
mécanisme de défense en fait on se dit
c'est celui qui tombe ce n'est pas moi
et on en éprouve une forme de
contentement et surtout je vais vous
dire quand c'est sa collègue Marie
bonnisso qui chute
[Rires]
[Musique]
je fais vraiment mon maximum et je me
dis voilà on n'a pas le choix il faut
tout donner parce que ça se joue
peut-être sur les piments quoi
moi je veux aller au bout de Pékin
Express c'est notre rêve donc s'il faut
manger des piments bon moi j'ai des
piments tant pis
pour me faire chier ici je suis dégoûté
encore une fois passe pour des cons pas
Messi il n'existant on l'a pas vu on est
éliminé voilà encore une fois saison de
merde saison de merde on regarde jamais
la Ligue des Champions c'est fini on est
foutu les supporters parisiens n'en peux
plus sur les réseaux sociaux personne
n'était Parné surtout pas les stars on
se demande si bah peramo s'est Messi
n'avait pas été remplacé par des sosies
hier à Munich pour les internautes
l'Argentin était transparent un petit
Messie donc même bapé a été plus
maladroit qu'à la coutumée
forcément à Marseille on savoure la
Provence ressort la photo qui fait mal
au Parisien alors Johan au-delà au-delà
de la déception est-ce que c'est pas
quelque part le mercato que vous êtes en
train de payer en ce moment
tu as le meilleur joueur du monde tu as
Messi Messi inexistant inexistant on l'a
pas vu on l'a pas vu le mec
sérieux on était nul on éliminé voilà
encore une fois ces jours de merde
saison de merde on est foutu c'est fini